salut vous vous souvenez il ya quelques
mois on a fait un nouveau style de
castet sur la chaîne qui s'appelle le
perplexus donc c'est une espèce de
labyrinthe un truc en plus c'est hyper
scientifique dans la manière d'avoir son
rapport à la gravité et qui se tourne
dans tous les sens pour faire circuler à
une bille à l'intérieur jeudi une sorte
de l'environnent parce que c'est pas
vraiment un avenir at il ya qu'un seul
chemin
par contre c'est ricky il faut faire
preuve de patience d'agilité de
concentration de vérifier s'il ya des
bords de tous les côtés il ya un peu des
acrobaties bref c'est extrêmement coulé
il ya une gamme très large on avait fait
les originales sur de cette chaîne on en
a fait deux sur la chaîne secondaire
vous avez un lien à la description est
au dessus de moi si je n'oublie pas de
le mettre
on a fait le epic et leurs outils et là
ils en ont un autre qui s'appelle le
harry potter ils ont obtenu la licence
harry potter on a le même support que ça
c'est pas le support de la coupe de feu
à la base annoncé le support des
prophéties qui sort juste devant moi ça
c'est la prophétie dari et ils ont ils
ont le même support ici ils ont donné
des noms tu vois par exemple tu as les
escaliers de poudlard qui sont par là
ici là tu les vois loide peut-être sur
cette caméra là ce sont les escaliers de
poudlard
donc voilà il ya plein de trucs
aujourd'hui nous allons essayer tenter
de résoudre le plus rapidement possible
le harry potter pourquoi le plus
rapidement possible parce que il n'est
que 170 étape le original et en sens
étaples et piqué en 125 étape on va
l'essayer
les soixante dix étapes le plus
rapidement possible sur cette chaîne on
va essayer de battre un record on va
essayer de le finir quand même le chrono
et là je pense pas faire un score de ouf
parce que je vais quand même aller
relativement lentement je suis pas
entraînée sur celui ci mais en face le
tenter quand même là plexus pour ceux
qui sont intéressés c'est eux qui m'ont
envoyé merci beaucoup à eux merci
perplexus donc le lien dans la
description on peut le trouver en
commande en ligne via le lien dans la
description ou directement dans les
magasins de jouets c'est parti will
garde home lait bio ça
expédia mousse manges tu es mort j'ai dû
felix felicis avec moi donc je vais le
boire qui va me permettre de réussir
tout ce que j'entreprends dans la
journée avec le 3 2 1 go 1 2 ok 2 ça
descend 3 jusqu'ici tout va bien
4 on rectifie on contourne on va là on
va par l'intérieur ok ça numéro 5
ok ça va aussi au 6 septembre et je ne
sais pas ce que je dois faire je te
passe hélas pour revenir là ok ça c'est
un petit truc à la con
on m'a vu dans l'épique perdent souvent
à cela mais cela ils sont plus faciles
ok on va ici on va là on retourne là où
je vais commenter un peu bizarrement et
alors qu'est ce qu'il y a c'est normal
c'est un record il faut que je sois
concentré je peux pas être divertissant
et faire des blagues tout en disant ça
tu vois ce que je veux dire
et là j'ai dit que c'était en combien en
70 ans et je sais pas quelle étape je
suis mais je suis clairement pas là 35
doit être vert le 19 au kg mickaël
marqué 19 les escaliers tout cela on les
a passés ils ont pas bougé
bien sûr fafa ici on a le petit ton qui
ressemble à un phallus en fait pas se
mentir moment donné ça nous met ici ok
là attention ces cris puis on y va très
lentement ok tac ça c'est bon là il y en
a dans ce sens là on le passe ici et là
on repasse le même mais dans l'autre
sens et c'est super bien conçu je ne
sais pas qui elles sont les ingénieurs
qu'on travaille là dessus mais c'est
trop bien
nar vient de passer le 30 je crois et là
je tombe ici ok qu'est ce que je dois
faire quand je suis là
c'est pas si clair que ça ok ok et il
faut contourner
d'accord c'est bon je suis passé à 96,6
jeu dans le bon sens ah oui bien il ya
une transparence avec le décor et les
flèches et du coup c'est pas toujours
très claires ou est-ce qu'on doit aller
allez on continue on continue on est aux
35 avait pas de rôle bord mais on l'a
passé quand même sévère parce qu'on n'a
pas que ça à faire ou là des escaliers
dangereux ok on ne passe ici on arrive
là jusqu'ici fait face s'en sort bien il
arrive gentiment aux 40
il passe par là et il arrive aux 40 2 le
42e on y va lentement parce qu'il faut
rectifier pour aller aux 15,3 on
commence à avoir un peu de ce qu'ils
dedans on arrive aux 40 hockey je suis à
combien de temps le hic c'est vrai mais
bien parce que j'ai commencé à dix
secondes
[Musique]
et fabien le fab qui perd beaucoup trop
de temps sur cette étape mais qu'ils
avaient peur de tomber
on a un petit manque de confiance due au
lit car qui approchent de la cicatrice
dari on vient de passer sept cicatrices
en 3d pour aller aux 48 le tube oh
qu'elle habille et ici on la voit par
transparence donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut la faire passer ici comme ça pour
qu'elle sorte directement l'a aidé à
faire aux dons des gentils mots ici
qu'elle est au bon endroit oui c'est
incroyable nous arrivons au 51 et
maintenant nous passons à 52 avec un
petit escalier qui nous mène vers
l'atelier de rock puisque nous sommes
maintenant dans les sous sols de
poudlard
on arrive maintenant la houlala
doucement doucement fans excusez-moi je
parle moins je mets ma cape
d'invisibilité
et personne n'a vu que j'étais passé ok
là il ya plus de robots donc on va
commencer à se la jouer tranquillement
sévère
quand je dis à plus de remords il ya
toujours un rebord mais pas des deux
côtés on arrive aux 57 58 on reprend
l'escalier de tout l'arc d'un côté
attention il n'y a pas d'euro bord de
l'autre côté c'est dangereux on descend
du labo d'astronomie arriver ici et là
on est au 59 j'ai dit que c'était en
soixante dix étapes
c'est là où faut pas faire le l'imbécile
est-ce qu'on fait le fil foule à loïc ne
fait pas le ok ok ok ok 61 oui 62 oh oh
fabien est retombée il est retombé en
arrière et du coup il reprend la partie
mais il est revenu aux 45
attention repasse la cicatrice dari on
repasse par le tube ya une sorte de 2
qui porte au loin
comme ça par là ok on repasse par là on
a perdu beaucoup trop de temps on
descend les escaliers on passe par le
bureau de rogue fin de bureau mais sa
salle de cours pour les potions on passe
par ici
est-ce que c'est ici que j'ai chuté un
peu non non non là j'avais mis ma cape
d'invisibilité tout le monde s'en
souvient
ici il n'y avait pas de rebords on
faisait très attention du coup voilà ce
qui nous a menés là ok et les escaliers
pour descendre du labo d'astronomie
voilà on est revenu je crois vers là où
j'ai perdu pas j'ai perdu je suis revenu
en arrière on est au 59 annoncés tels
actes chez on fait très attention ce
coup ci merci beaucoup
ok on est parti sur le terrain de
quidditch
on a fait tout le tour on repasse par
ici une passe 61 ça passe de 62 ça passe
ok on est au 60e pourquoi ya pas de
rebords ont fait que ces attentions
c'est gentiment 64 attention oui
on passe à l'intérieur on voit pas trop
ce qu'on sait mais on a confiance en qui
on a confiance en la vie la confiance à
l'amour la confiance en l'amitié 65
ça passe sans rebord 66 ça passe sans
rebord 67 attention va faire
l'équilibriste un oui ça passe grave
ok on descend par ce petit escalier à
l'intérieur on passe ou la gco du touch
ok on repasse comme ça et là je crois
qu'on va arriver aux 70 70 nous sommes
dans les jardins de madame chou rave on
a réussi je propose qu'on tente de
battre ce record la garde
est-ce que fabien battre à son propre
camp c'est le défi que je vais relever
aujourd'hui challenge de 1 go par de
temps inutile fab
c'est ça que tu veux faire ta vie par du
temps fabien c'est ça c'est ça ta vie
c'est perdre du temps ce taux martyrise
il n'a besoin de personne pour ce métier
si j'ai permis
dommage
parce que c'est ça que dalle
tu as sorti un livre qui s'appelle votre
temps est infinie apparemment
tu es fini quoi
a toujours ce problème de coordination
fabien j'ai perdu moins de temps que les
premières fois et sachant que j'ai
ralenti un petit peu parce que on voit
très bien ce que ça donne quand je vais
beaucoup trop trop trop vite au bout
d'un moment je le vois un chez moi
explique que les des coudes avant où
j'étais super bien sur le timing et si
c'est pour finir après à la baille et
aux 51
[Musique]
[ __ ] je l'avais pas ces gens là là
j'ai perdu au moins trois secondes de
ouf le dommage de faire ça d'être si
bien en pole position et les un moment
donné sur un virage
dépassé par le déplacement c'est là on a
dit tu allais faire attention
[Musique]
record à battre
quand on compte au togo
non
on part en 17
piette
je sens sa tanière
[Musique]
il
et stop [ __ ] de 47 je les fait sourire
je suis copain de 47 je retenterai
surtout il joue sur un stade où vous les
liens s'affiche ici je retenterai
j'essaierai de descendre un peu plus bas
vraiment objectif final pour moi dans ma
vie c'est de taper en moins de deux
minutes 47 secondes je sais pas s'il
veut peut-être déjà de 30 descendre en
dessous des 2 30 dans un premier temps
ça fait dix-sept secondes à gagner c'est
pas rien ouais c'est ça en dessous des 2
30 c'est pas mal merci beaucoup
perplexus de m'avoir envoyé tout ça
n'hésitez pas perplexus accrue continue
à m'envoyer vos nouveautés j'aime
beaucoup les faire
lien dans la description pour l'obtenir
via le lien sur internet également
disponible dans les magasins de jouets
merci à vous si vous voulez voir les
autres y sont sur la chaîne secondaire
pour la version épique et la version
rookie merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo pensez à vous abonner à très
bientôt ciao